here's a riddle what do greeting cards
family secrets and the nosy neighbor
have in common
you don't have to solve the puzzle we'll
just tell you the batman is littered
with small details that only the most
dedicated fans could spot
the movie's version of the riddler takes
after the zodiac killer in more ways
than one not only does he done a
terrifying mask he wears when he targets
his victims but he also leaves behind
puzzles and ciphers for the detectives
to solve specifically he leaves behind
greeting cards for batman himself and
inside contain clues that help reveal
what he is actually looking for in all
of this however fans will want to pay
attention to the outside of those cards
they may not mean much to the characters
in the film but fans should recognize
that each card contains a reference to a
different batman adversary for instance
the first card we see features an owl it
may come across as a spooky halloween
card initially but fans should recognize
the correlation to the court of owls
from the comics that's not the only
reference hidden in the cards the second
one has a hugo strange like mad
scientist the third feature is a
beautiful woman who looks an awful lot
like poison ivy the fourth has a set of
eyes reminiscent of the cheshire cat
hinting toward mad hatter and the fifth
card includes a boy with a puppet in an
obvious reference to scarface and the
ventriloquist each card subtly
references a different caped crusader
villain
and honestly any of them would make for
a terrifying foe for the batman 2.
the batman differs from previous batman
films by not necessarily depicting the
murder of thomas and martha wayne
instead their deaths are merely alluded
to and end up playing a significant role
in the cover-up riddler wants to expose
during one sequence featuring heavy
exposition we learn the truth behind the
two most prominent families to ever
grace gotham the waynes and the arkhams
we learn that during thomas wayne's run
for mayor a reporter threatened to
expose martha's time being
institutionalized in arkham asylum
martha hasn't been related to the
arkhams in any of the movies before
so this is something of a reference to
the earth 1 storyline where her last
name is arkham before marrying thomas
wayne and that's not the only familial
connection the movie makes
even casual moviegoers know who batman's
parents are but selena kyle's lineage is
more up in the air while it's gone
through some changes over the years the
batman decides to borrow elements from
the long halloween and dark victory
making catwoman's true father carmine
falcone the film establishes that her
mother maria kyle died a long time ago
and she wants to get close enough to
falcone to kill him for what she did to
her mom in the long halloween and dark
victory comics the relationship between
selena and carmine is far more
circumstantial while she has a strong
hunch that carmine is her father she
doesn't have any definitive proof she's
far more sure of herself in the movie
prior to the release of the batman a bug
set collection came out gathering dark
knight stories that influenced the
latest feature film among them was
batman year one even though director
matt reeves explained that the movie
wouldn't be an origin story like we've
seen in the past still as one of the
most definitive batman stories it's
understandable that the book would
influence the first chapter of a new
batman story and you can see that in how
the movie recreates one of the most
significant scenes in that storyline in
year one a catwoman scratches a side of
carmine falcone's face resulting in claw
scars remaining a fixture of his
character a similar scene occurs in the
batman when catwoman claws at carmine's
face with her extra long nails he sports
that look throughout the rest of his
time in the batman
most moviegoers should have a passing
familiarity with the riddler and
probably know his true identity as
edward nigma this has been his real name
in the likes of batman forever and
gotham in true comic book fashion the
name shortens to enigma or enigma which
is appropriate for a man who loves
puzzles and riddles however for some the
name might be a bit too cartoony for
more serious fare which is why this new
version of the character has the name of
edward nashton as it happens though
there's a comic book precedent for even
this change in the comic books post
crisis on infinite earth it's
established that riddler's birth name is
edward nashton that allows the character
to have a more grounded persona but in
true comic book form he changes his last
name to enigma to better fit his new
persona it's not hard to figure out why
matt reeves went with nashton over
enigma the film takes on the tone of a
dark noir film so a name like enigma
probably wouldn't work for the more
realistic feel of the movie still reeves
managed to squeeze in a nod to riddler's
alternate names throughout his comic
book continuity when riddlers
apprehended at the diner the police find
two alternate ids on his person hinting
at the various names he'd held over the
years
another major moment pulled straight
from the comics occurs during the
beginning of the film's final act as
batman confronts riddler who's locked
away in arkham asylum he reveals that
the machinations of his grand final plan
are already well underway in this
instance the batman finale takes place
in a gotham that's been flooded by water
after various flood walls break apart in
an explosion set forth by riddler and
his henchmen the plan should be familiar
to anyone who read the zero year comic
book arc in that storyline riddler
manages to do the same thing flooding
gotham and turning it into an
apocalyptic wasteland
an intriguing development occurs during
the big climatic final battle between
batman and catwoman versus ridler's
henchmen at a certain point batman
becomes too overpowered to help him get
back on his feet batman takes out a vial
containing a green substance which he
uses to inject himself suddenly he
receives a strength to get back on his
feet and pummel the final riddler
henchmen into submission it might take
some fans by surprise especially seeing
how the vial wasn't set up earlier in
the film however fans of the comics may
recognize the substance as having
similar properties to venom which is
what bane uses to give himself super
strength
and now i had
my super soldier serum
codenamed
after all like in the comics it does
appear to give batman a boost in energy
and strength it also vastly increases
his hostility as he goes way over the
limit beating up the [ __ ] to the point
where the gotham pd have to pull him off
that level of savagery could also be
attributed to what we've seen out of
venom in the past could this mean that
bane could appear in a subsequent batman
movie similar to riddler's greeting
cards it could just be a fun easter egg
to hint at a larger world out there
after all the universe of the batman
will be further explored in an hbo max
tv series centered on gotham pd and
penguin so there are plenty of avenues
for bane to make his way into this
franchise
by the end of the film batman has
stopped the riddler's reign of terror
and put him safely behind bars at arkham
asylum however there's someone in a cell
next to riddler who manages to put a
smile on that face once again while
they're never mentioned by name we can
make a pretty educated guess riddler's
neighbor makes a reference to how one
day a person can feel like they're on
top of the world but the next day the
world sees them as a clown then he
begins laughing maniacally in such a
manner that gets riddler chuckling too
it's easy to put two and two together
and surmise that this individual played
by barry kyogin will be the latest
iteration of joker in the credits this
character is listed as unseen arkham
prisoner so it does give those working
behind the scenes some leeway as to
whether they want to pursue a joker
storyline for a future installment of
the batman series after all when asked
about who would like to introduce in a
sequel matt reeves surprisingly picked
mr freeze still it's exciting to think
that joker is out there somewhere just
waiting to bring some joy to gotham
[Laughter]
for years warner brothers tried to get a
shared cinematic universe up and running
with the dc extended universe this
established that films like man of steel
wonder woman and aquaman all existed
within the same timeline similar to what
marvel had accomplished with the mcu
over the years the franchise has been
met with mixed responses so dc has
branched off into other separate
entities since the beginnings of the dc
eu the batman falls into that category
it exists in its own separate timeline
completely detached from what ben
affleck had done during his tenure as
the dark knight
is she with you
i don't choose with you
as such there aren't too many references
to other dc properties outside of the
batman mythos however it does manage to
accomplish a bit of world building that
could easily pay off down the line
toward the end of the flick catwoman
mentions how she's going to get out of
gotham for a while and perhaps head up
to bloodhaven the name should sound
familiar to anyone who's read the batman
comics or checked out arrow on the cw
the fictional city has come up
frequently in dc comics over the years
as a nearby locale to gotham in fact
when nightwing decides to venture out as
his own hero he sets up his base of
operations in bloodhaven to get away
from batman what does this mean for the
future of the batman it might mean
nothing and serve as solely a way to get
catwoman out of the picture to make room
for other characters and the batman too
but it's good to know that if dick
grayson ever enters a fold bloodhaven is
there awaiting its protector
it's become commonplace for superhero
movies to contain mid or post-credit
scenes fans have come to anticipate a
fun joke or a teaser of what's to come
you're still here
it's over
go home
no doubt plenty of theatergoers will
wait around until the credits are
finished to see if the batman has
anything worth sticking around for while
there's no teaser scene at the very end
of the batman it does show a blink and
you'll miss it tag of a web address
viewers remember this is a url batman
and gordon had to visit about halfway
through the movie when they realized
riddler gave them a web address as it
turns out you can actually visit this
url it will take you to a website where
you'll encounter some of riddler's
puzzles attempting to answer them to
reveal the truth it appears the riddles
are different each time you visit the
site but one of the trick questions
you'll encounter is from birth to death
from boy to man all things change but
this is one thing he will always be
and don't think you can get any hints on
other websites if you click away from
the page you're greeted with a message
reading you scour the internet for the
truth but you still need to answer me
what does it all lead to we won't spoil
the fun of you figuring out the riddle
on your own
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the batman are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]